I told you months ago that Donald Trump was
preparing to censor the Internet for political
gain and it's going to happen, or at least
he's going to try and I'm going to tell you
about it, but let's think back to the foundation
of all of this.
The foundation of all of this actually goes
to quote fake news, Fake News, and talking
about journalism licenses as Donald Trump
has done, and talking about shutting down
certain media outlets and talking about how
social media is just all left wing and they've
really got to do something about it.
I told you from the beginning, it was all
a pretext to eventually try to clamp down
on Internet speech politically along political
lines.
And then a couple of months ago, Trump had,
maybe it was a month ago, Trump had this just
comically laughable social media summit at
the White House.
And of course, no left-wingers were invited.
I pointed this out at the time and of course
the entire pretext of the social media summit
was that, oh, the right is being censored
online and it's also unfair.
None of it is true, of course.
And now politico has learned over the weekend
that there are drafts going around of an executive
order by Donald Trump, which would be a truly
authoritarian nightmare.
The likes of which I don't believe we've ever
seen before in the modern sort of internet
news era.
What we know so far is a draft of the order
exists.
It would allow the administration to fight
back against what they say, our liberal cesspools
on social media.
And it is believed that there would be penalties
for a social media company that quote censors
political viewpoints.
And this is, I can't, it's almost impossible
to explain the severity of what is going on
now.
No one yet has gone on record about what the
penalties would be to social media platforms,
but this is truly a free speech horror.
Let me explain to you why it's so dangerous.
Twitter has policies, for example, against
bullying trans people by mis-gendering them
as just one example.
The left believes this is simply an issue
of treating people correctly.
It's an issue of Internet bullying period.
It's not political issue and the same way
that we'd not argue today that a policy against
calling black people, the n word is not a
political issue.
Most of us, I know that there are some out
and out racist who would disagree, but in
2019 most people understand a policy on a
social media platform against targeting black
people with the n word is not a political
policy.
It's just we treat people in a respectful
way in the way that they should be treated.
That is the view of Twitter when it comes
to deliberately mis-gendering people to the
point of it being bullying the right believes
and has said that merely having a policy around
bullying that includes how you gender people
on the Internet is a left wing bias.
So this gets us back to Donald Trump's potential
internet censorship policy.
A policy like what Donald Trump is proposing
would supposedly prescribe punishments for
limiting political speech and they would argue
that a policy against anti-trans speech, including
deliberately mis-gendering people in a way
that is bullying is politically biased action
by Twitter.
They would argue that Twitter, by not allowing
incessant mis-gendering to the point of bullying,
Twitter is silencing a political viewpoint,
which I guess is the political viewpoint that
it's fine to mis-gender trans people deliberately
to the point of bullying.
Can you see how dangerous this is?
This is an incoming fascistic restriction
on speech from those who claim.
Remember that they're all about speech, they
don't want to limit speech, and we can actually
simplify a ton of what's underlying this.
Trump doesn't like people saying things about
them on the Internet and he wants to find
a way to either make it illegal or to make
it punishable by fines or some kind of other
penalty.
Of course, there are a lot of right wingers
who have other priorities here and they happen
to line up with Donald Trump.
They believe social media is all left wing,
all that stuff.
They do believe it, but it's super easy to
get Trump on board by telling him, Mr President,
you can punish the companies that are allowing
all of these mean things to be said about
you.
These are private companies.
Conservative supposedly are all for private
companies making their rules and functioning
with as little regulation as possible.
Why don't conservatives just leave these platforms,
start their own sort of like a gate, a couple
finding a different baker to bake them a cake.
The truth is it's a lie.
They don't really like private business and
a marketplace of ideas.
If the ideas of the business or the marketplace
aren't the ones that they like.
If anything, Twitter is going easy on things
that violate their terms and conditions because
if Twitter actually enforced the terms and
conditions on Donald Trump's Twitter account,
he would have been banned by now.
Trump regularly bullies people on Twitter.
Trump regularly threatens violence on Twitter.
The sort of glimmer of hope here, because
this executive order from what we know so
far looks truly horrifying.
The one glimmer of hope is that courts strike
this down, but remember that increasingly
Trump controls the courts.
Trump has two supreme court justices that
he has selected.
I believe Trump is now selected 25% of it
may be district and appellate courts.
We did the story last week and I forget the
numbers, but the point is Trump is increasingly
controlling.
Every month Trump has more control over the
court system that would ultimately adjudicate
whether this incoming executive order is even
legal.
So we've got to get him out now, which really
means November of 2020 I don't know any other
way around it.
It's, it must be done because this now is
starting to become a true authoritarian nightmare
even for things as simple as just speech on
the Internet.
As soon as I have more details about the executive
order draft, I will absolutely get them to
you.
Make sure you're following the David Pakman
show on Instagram at David Pakman show.
I did post a few hours ago a tomato update,
my tomato plants, big developments with my
tomato plants in the literal and proverbial
sense over the weekend and I posted
there's a story to my Instagram page, David.
Dot. Patrick, check that out.
We'll take a quick break and do back after
that,